oh my god that looks great
that's crazy
hi everyone it's nicole russell from
last dragon pizza and welcome to peace
awards on first week feast
every week i'm battling some of my
favorite chefs on my journey to become
the world's next master pizzola
today i'm facing off with mike
greenfield from the youtube channel pro
home cooks
and we're going to be preparing our
favorite movie inspired pieces
obviously there's only one man who can
judge this event the movie pizza master
binging with babish today i'll be making
the legendary pizza in a cup from the
movie the jerk
pizza in the cup in the movie is like in
a styrofoam cup
and truly you can't even see the pizza
when steve martin is eating it so you
know i wanted to see the pizza
i want to show the crust the cheese
bubbling on the top and the pepperoni
i think it's going to come out great
my name is mike greenfield i am the
creator of the pro home cooks youtube
page
so when babish challenged me to make the
pizza from inside out
i was very excited because i love that
movie i love all movies from pixar
they show the front of the pizza place
and they make fun of san francisco
for ruining pizza because they put
broccoli on the pizza
so this pizza is gonna be a white pizza
with
broccoli on top but there's a few twists
and turns to kind of take it
to the next level and make it taste
incredible at least that's the goal
last week i lost to frank pinella and
that's okay he's a legend you know what
i mean
but this week i'm out for blood come on
i gotta win this
[Music]
mike thank you so much for being here
i'm super excited
what are you making today i'm happy to
be here on this little pizza duel
so today i'm making a sourdough white
pizza the movie they don't actually talk
about sourdough but when i watch
babish's video
he took it upon himself to make a
sourdough pie because
that pizza was based in san francisco
and i love everything sourdough
naturally fermented dough
is like your friend because it's like
even though you can make it wait a long
time
when it hits that heat it performs like
no other so that's why i like it too
now i'm gonna take this out and i'm just
gonna form it into
some dough balls okay i'll let them sit
for
30 minutes just to let the gluten rest
before i start rolling it out
so it was a broccoli pizza i'm using
some broccolini here
which is just another variety i'm going
to roast these but not
totally through it's going to go on the
pie and bake as well so you're not going
to roast them completely
exactly gotcha put a little bit olive
oil on the tray
a little bit of salt and then i will
roast these like i said these are just
kind of par roasting because it's a
white pizza
we need to add extra flavor right
so what i'm gonna do is make a garlic
butter
who doesn't love garlic butter i know
it's almost cheating
so you can see this butter now is
sizzling oh it looks you just want to
you want to see that gentle
butter sizzle right there i think i'm
ready to roll out pizza
okay for this i'm just pushing it out
with my fingers
kind of leaving a crust and then i'll
start
working it and letting gravity take over
see how he has his fingers
it's not poking through the dough that's
where you can tell the gluten is formed
and ready to go we're gonna go in
with that garlic butter and i'm gonna do
a whole layer of this
on the crust as well oh that's gonna
brown really nicely
it's gonna brown the crust but really
it's like your sauce yes
this is your sauce right here and now
i'm actually gonna go around with some
sesame seeds
so i just chopped up this broccoli and
uh you know bite-sized pieces
also broccoli first yeah cause i like
when the cheese melts over it
okay so i got the mozzarella on there
now i'm gonna go in
with cottage cheese we'll just do a few
dollops
yes here and there and then just a
little bit of chili flake
now that's ready to go on i'll just
great look at this a little
pull little judge little judge
and i'm just going to slide that in
[Music]
pulling it a home pie people think you
can't make great pizza at home look at
that
yes oh listen to that crunch
this sourdough pizza looks amazing that
crumb on it is so good i can't wait to
take a bite
we got a little bit of flop oh my god
i got to bring my a game my a game
do you think that you nailed it i feel
like the inside out pizza
that was a little more classic pizza
shop a little more basic
i think this was taking the general
concept of a white pizza with broccoli
and just trying to give it my little
you know flare extra flavor well well
done
thank you you're giving me some stiff
competition
let's see if i can beat them
okay mine your pizza was great but are
you ready for pizza in a cup
i'm interested i think this is going to
be super interesting and super fun yeah
is this a first for you this is a first
you're not selling pizza in a cup too
i'm never gonna
probably not so what i did was i
buttered my mug yeah
right just got some butter in there and
to give a little outside crispiness i'm
gonna take some semolina you ever use
semolina yeah i do
so i'm gonna do the same thing for yours
okay put a little something you're
making me a personal cheese cup
of course you're my guest thank you
we're gonna just drop this dough in here
but what you want to do is
not stretch it out too much because you
don't want when it goes in the overlap
to be like crazy right yeah
how many times did you have to test this
well i did it like twice honestly i
didn't go
crazy because i didn't want to get super
scientific with pizza in a cup
yeah but i wanted to make it good yeah
and make it fun
after i put this in the cup we're gonna
bake this i'm gonna make it brown
ah so you're par baking car making it
correct okay
i feel like a little mad scientist yeah
you excited yeah
all right
okay i just took these out of the oven
um they're par bake and
now i'm gonna fill them what i would
love to do is slide these out let's see
if it works
yeah baby they're coming out
i think babish is going to be impressed
because i doubt he went to this level
now let's fill this baby up pizza and a
cup one thing to
realize when doing this you know cheese
is voluminous like this when you put it
in here it drops
yeah so you got to put a lot of cheese
in here
and you want to put a lot of cheese
because you want it to like stretch and
be gooey
yeah all right gonna put some pepperoni
in here in between the cheese a little
bit
i'm gonna put some sauce in here drop it
in the top
so you see we're getting to the top it's
starting to look like a pizza
yeah all right so i'm gonna bake this
again for about another 10 minutes
okay to make sure the center gets nice
and gooey i'll open it up for you thank
you you're the best
piece in a cup i keep saying it like a
[ __ ]
[Music]
okay moment of truth you ready i'm one
excited please
i'm super excited oh my god
it looks like pizza in a cup oh my god
doesn't that look amazing
this is an exciting thing to be served
you're so used to
being served a pizza it's like i know
how to eat a pizza right
this is a new experience you think so
yes i thought it would be so fun
all right so you ready to taste this bad
boy oh it's a dipper yes
it's a straight dipper wow
it's kind of like you have to craft a
bite
pizza and a cup the crust is so amazing
it definitely has a childhood effect i
bite into that
something's bringing me back like
something that you would take out of
the freezer and pop in the oven but much
more gourmet
giving me some ideas there yeah the way
you pulled this off
very impressive very technical and it
tastes good
okay well we had two amazing pieces
today
there's only one thing left to do go to
the judges table and there's only one
man for the job
andrew ray benjing the babbage let's do
it
andrew thank you so much for joining us
mike and i worked super hard today to
recreate your recipes
what makes a great recreation of a dish
from a movie or
tv show well it's got to look like the
food
but it's got a taste halfway decent very
difficult balance to strike i'm
curious to see how you guys are going to
do it mike you're up
chef please explain your offering to me
so
what i did here was i created a white
pizza from inside out
i like the research you did that was
enough for me when you said sourdough in
your video
i ran with that and then i have some
broccolini on there
and three cheeses let's take a look at
this we got some good amazing bubblage
great bubs on this
way better than mine was so that's a
little embarrassing so i'm gonna grab a
slice here let's take a look at the
bottom
great char on the bottom which doing
that in a home oven
only you could pull that off and what's
great is i'm gonna be able to get
everything in one bite here if i just
hit this spot real good
hit that spot
okay i had to tug on it a little bit
thank you for your offering
i'm glad you appreciate the offering for
your execution
in terms of recreating the thing from
the movie
yeah great job because uh
this this place that they were
referencing in the movie very artisanal
pizza
high-end ingredients uh uh creative
stuff and you were very creative here
i can imagine that this is the kind of
thing that they would serve and the
sourdough
kicked the [ __ ] out of mine so that is
yeah that's kind of my specialty on
those merits i i must
give you very high marks great all
around oh
my stars and garters so today
babish i prepared for you pizza in a cup
from the movie the jerk i was super
inspired by what you did but i just
wanted to make it a little bit more
artisan
and just please you so i hope you love
it consider me
please just from looking at it that is
spectacular
it's like a choose your own adventure
it's crazy it really is
oh my god that looks great but
that's crazy i can swear on this channel
right
i'm not gonna be able to help myself
this is just pork full of cheese
i'm so in awe that you've succeeded at
making pizza in a cup
because the joke in that movie is that
it's pizza in a cup it doesn't make
sense and uh the fact that you were able
to take a joke food and make something
genuinely amazing out of it is a triumph
you should be very very proud
thank you so much and this is coming
from a guy who really doesn't know what
he's talking about
that means a lot
[Music]
all right andrew we're both pretty
stoked so have you made a decision who
wins
chefs
chef mike your pizza was very very very
very good
chef nicole your pizza was very very
very very good
but you'll notice that one of those had
one more very did it
i can't remember uh but at the end of
the day only one of you can take home
the golden the pizza wars award
this is painted by the way
i'm sorry so only one of you gets the
golden pizza
and that person that chef
is i'll give you that again clean out
and that chef is
this is spanish i'm scared audience
who do you think was he's dropping his
place
the winner is nicole oh
really congratulations this
is as about as inventive and crazy
and beautiful as art indeed can be
oh thank you but it's also pizza which
is [ __ ] awesome i can't wait to watch
this episode because i want to see how
you did this
it's so impressive well i appreciate you
so much and it was my honor to do that
for you
that was my honor to eat it do i have
anything in my teeth do you have any
sesame seeds
okay we're good
this is incredible i'm so happy that i
won and everyone at home make sure you
tune in next week
to peace awards who will nicole beat
next week
[Music]
you